it legal for you to work on a Tesla car
after working for them on the side they
sued me they tried to sue me and
basically wrote go after yourself on the
envelope send it back originally they
tried to say I wasn't qualified what
they didn't know was I was one of the
people that were certifying body shops
at the time if I'm incompetent to work
on the cars how was I competent enough
to train the people to work on the cars
and then they're like white as ghosts
and that was an end of my conversation
with Tesla legal what do you think the
issue was that they didn't want someone
who wasn't within their organization
working on a car it was all based on how
I was terminated right I was terminated
for steal so they don't want somebody
with that credibility problem working on
their car so that's why they went after
me the truth was I never stole anything
that was proven later